my name is Igor and I will talk about
performance of vector databases uh just
a few words about me I work as sdt
developer in test for more than five
almost six years and I started with
developing of
internal uh automation platform for
infrastructure provisioning and autot
testing and stuff like this and then I
worked on testing of internal message
bus very high loaded
for
um uh for trading platform and then I
developed infrastructure tools uh for
like for kubernetes Docker that kind of
stuff uh in tin of bank and currently I
work at superbase and uh in superbase I
do uh different kind of tools uh to
improve quality quality of products and
developer experience for inside
Developers for outside developers and
what is superbase superbase is an
open-source Firebase alternative that uh
empowers you to create your applications
Faster by providing a set of tools that
are also all open source and they based
on pogress and they use pogress a lot
and uh they do authentication user
management out of the box also provide
apis uh Edge functions real time storage
S3 Integrations and Vector uh Vector is
based on PG Vector open source extension
and uh why do we need it at all uh this
will be our talk today uh so we will
cover like a bit of theory about
embeddings uh what is retrieval
argumented generation and other use
cases for embeddings uh then about
Vector databases and how to Benchmark
them and we finish with a little bit
like practical example how to load test
uh performance test your database so uh
embeddings uh they came like super
popular last year and we can see because
the usage of PG Vector uh increases like
by very high margin like it maybe go
like 100 times more than before uh when
the
chpt gain its popular ity um so what are
embeddings embeddings uh
uh they generally capture the
relatedness of text images videos or any
other kind of information
to um to perform later a uh similarity
search uh and how it looks like we can
pass some documents uh to the machine
learning model that will generate from
this like discrete information uh a
vector uh that's it so embedding is
generate a vector and uh if we as a
human will be given a task to group this
kind of sentences it will be pretty easy
right so first two uh generally is the
same thing and the third one is uh not
from this world uh it's super easy but
for the computer it's not as easy uh
because uh like semantically the first
and the second sentence they don't have
similar words except the and uh
embeddings are made to were created to
like cover this task and after the
machine learning model will process it
and turn it into vectors we would expect
this vectors to be located something
like this so these two will be somewhere
close to each other and I like H
sandwiches will be far away from it uh
um this is of course two-dimensional
space and in reality
embeddings much more High dimensional
for example other model by open a is
1536 dimensions and some open source
models like GTS small which is also very
good but works on with English for
example uh has
384 uh Dimensions some like for image
searches uh they're like a bit low lower
Dimension models like 200 something like
this but it's still um a lot so what are
use cases for embeddings uh it can be
like search recommendation system
clustering anomaly detection uh
classifications and all this stuff uh
one of it obviously is like image search
based on text queries or images and uh
why is Yandex here because they have a
very good data set with one billion uh
embeddings that you can use to
Performance to per test your dat datase
another one of course is Spotify and
when you enable when you turn on some
music uh for example mix for the day uh
beneath there is a uh embeddings model
and similarity
search uh and the use case which was
also like one of the most hot uh last
year is retrieval augumented generation
and uh I don't know if you're familiar
with it or not uh but the idea here is
that uh large language models uh are
prone to
hallucinations and uh uh one of the way
to um kind of overcome this
hallucination problem is to uh train the
model uh further on your data uh but it
can be uh not cost effective or you
cannot have access to model to do this
uh so much more straightforward and easy
way way to do this is to provide some
additional data additional context uh to
the large language models when you uh
give it some prompt uh for example it
may work like this you ask something uh
CH GPT or llama model whatever uh and
before you actually uh send a prompt to
it with your question you create an
embedding uh from your question you find
similar vectors to your question in the
database uh you retrieve this
information in form of text uh you add
it to the prompt with the original
question and you pass everything uh in
the context to the large language model
so it can uh provide more accurate us
results uh other ways to get the
relevant information may be like use
search just like Google it like Bing
does for example it splits your question
to multiple queries it search the
internet find some results and add it to
the prompt or if for example you have
very large platform uh and you renamed
it from Twitter tox recently you can
create embeds for all Tweets in the
world and launch Gro uh and it will
always have like the most relevant
information the most recent from the
tweets uh so if for example you don't
have uh access to this and you have
access to like loads of information in
your company like support ticket
and a lot of like Internal Documentation
that doesn't exist in the public
internet you maybe also want to do some
similarity search over this and you can
do this using Vector databases so you
will pass this information to the
embeddings model you get the imagings
you store everything in the vector
database and you want to uh search in
this database but you don't want to wait
like for an hour when uh you will find
the relevant information so there are
Vector index indexes that uh can speed
up your searches uh these are some
databases some of them are propri
proprietory uh not open with some custom
in-house indexes like Pine con some of
them are open source like milus and some
of them are just general purpose
databases like uh relational or click
house uh like columnar database or time
scale
for uh time series uh but they have like
extensions like posg for example with PG
Vector that allow you to Store and
search for
emits um and in terms of indexes there
are pretty a lot of them and these are
practical
implementations uh in different
databases uh and uh let's cover a couple
of them really quickly so uh the first
group is a three based algorithms for
approxim at nearest neighbor search uh
so we have KNN which is kind nearest
neighbor search which is always exact
nearest neighbors but it's pretty slow
in most situations if you have not if
you don't have a lot of compute to do uh
search in parallel um and a&n is
approximate nearest NE where you find
like you think they're pretty close that
you can return them as a results of
queries and uh Tre based algorithms they
split the space to like forests a group
of trees and then the searge kind of
goes over the short pass and search in
some of the trees which is generally
faster another way is lsh based
algorithms here
we apply several hash functions uh to
vectors and then we expect that vectors
that are close to each other will be in
the same hash pocket so you have to
search for small number of hash
buckets uh for the really close vectors
uh one of databases that actually use
this approach a lot is Click house uh
they buil one of their solutions for
Vector search on top of uh lsh uh and
another one is f by
meta uh another one is inverted file
index the picture looks pretty much like
trees but here we like also group group
vectors into uh segments we have like
nodes there and research only uh in one
or maybe in few uh uh close
clusters uh to find similar vectors PG
Vector uh initially worked with IVF flat
implementation and uh the last one I
will talk a little bit today is uh
hierarchal hierarchical navigatable
small wall
uh and here U it is a very efficient
algorithm it has the complexity of n log
n for all operations search insert
delete uh which make it very good so for
example with IVF flat uh you have to
rebuild index pretty frequent if you do
a lot of inserts or deletions uh with
hnsw you don't have to do this it will
remain uh effective and how it
works uh
it can be divided into two parts so the
first one is hierarchical and the second
one navigatable small W uh the second
part means that in our graph uh we have
nodes that uh are connected uh with
nodes that are close to each other and
also they have like long distance
connections and this helps with a pretty
fast search because if they will be all
connected only to notes that are close
to them the search will be uh pretty
long because you have to go uh through a
lot of hops but here we start at the
like at the high level we find uh where
the vectors are SPS less part sorry and
uh then we go down this chart until we
find the vector that is close uh to what
we
need uh and uh as you can see uh when we
go higher in uh
this
uh in layers uh we just Amit some
vectors uh
and this way like this level distributes
like long connections this longer and
this very short Dimensions so let's jump
to benchmarking uh when we choose the
vector database for our use case uh
we not only have like the performance
side of things we of course have to
evaluate like how good is a developer
experience with it how easy is to host
and manage this database but of course
benchmarking is here here uh as
well uh because we don't want our users
to wait too long uh to get the results
uh especially for search or
recommendation platforms maybe less for
U retrieval augment generation but uh
yeah so one of the most used uh tool is
Ann benchmarks it's Ann benchmarks repo
it's a python project uh made for
evaluation of uh databases and in
es and uh to add uh a new database for
testing in this project you just have to
implement a couple of methods in the
base Ann class uh for example uh you
have to implement initialized method
that will launch the
database
um uh then we have a fit uh to put
vectors into the database and create an
an index and then query uh
to do a query uh in the database we also
have a badge query which is acing uh and
we have to run badge query and get badge
results if we want to run queries in
batches uh and of course we can add uh
data sets to this project for this we
need to add a function that will load
that data set from internet somewhere uh
and split the data set uh to vectors for
uh storing in the database and for
quering uh we already saw a picture from
this project uh with a benchmark and
yeah it has a lot of databases tested uh
and you can contribute to it another one
that we will actually use today is
Vector DB Benchmark uh the repo is
created by quadrant uh there also a
vector database specialized Vector
database uh and uh they made this pretty
good project uh if I were you I would
also use this one because it's much
better
structured uh it uses op in a very
clever way uh and we will see it right
now so to add data set uh to this
project we only need to add a small
object into Json here we add DBP open 1M
data set in the previous one it was the
same data set so it is
uh a data set of 1 million embeddings
created with open AI a model for
Wikipedia
articles and uh what else we have here
so uh it is also easy to add data sets
here you can add to Json because there
is an interface for a reader of the data
set where you can read the data to uh
put into the database read the queries
uh and there are a couple of them
implemented already for n djon Json l or
H5 for
example uh and uh another part that we
may want to implement is obviously the
part to add new databases uh or indexes
for testing and here it is split into a
couple of files and a couple of
interfaces in the engine base client uh
if you want to follow on your phone you
can scan the core code it will lead to
this uh project here uh so so what we
have here we don't have to implement all
of them but couple of them we have to
the first one is base configurator and
it used to create a database initialize
it and do whatever we need so database
will
work uh and let's implement it for PG
Vector I will use Vex Library it is open
source and on GitHub uh you can find the
link later in the materials for the
stock uh we need to import it we need to
create a client for the database we can
also start the database here if you want
but uh I prefer testing this on Hardware
or distant virtual machines uh not in
Docker uh so I only create a client here
uh then we can clean the state uh of the
database uh for postgress PG Vector it
is pretty easy we just have to drop the
table and that's
it uh and uh of course create and new
table we have a dimension dimensions of
the data set of the vectors uh provided
by uh the data set itself uh so we can
use it to create a table uh with Vector
type um in the background Vex will uh
add an PGE Vector section if it's needed
we'll create some other stuff that maybe
needed it it can
also do some work for you and create
indexes if you don't know the best
parameters yourself yet uh so another
one is base uploader which is used for
uploading the data to the database and
it can also do a poster plot which can
be index creation for example and here
we again initialize the client uh the
Vex client
we uh Implement a PL bch method by just
doing upsert uh and post upload we
create index uh we can also pass here uh
index type IVF flat and hnsw supported
by PG vector and we can also pass
um index parameters here like for hnsw
it is M and EF construction which
control how precise will be the index
and how long it will be
built uh then we have base Searcher uh
well it is just for the query uh again
initialized uh the client and here we
just need need to use one method SE just
table query and use the vector that uh
was
passed uh by the base
client uh that that's actually
everything we need here and uh the last
bit uh is create an experiment uh it is
also a Json configuration uh we can uh
every experiment can be split into two
parts the first one is a plot part where
when we upload vectors and we create an
index and the second one is the search
and we can control how many threads will
be used to query the
database uh it can affect results
significantly of
course uh I wanted to do this live uh
but I was afraid about an internet so I
made a
recording um so uh to run it we just run
a python command just run a python
script uh and I run only the upload part
uh using the parameter skip
search uh it's a bit speed up video tic
uh or
so
uh there will be like 3 minutes to
upload the vectors and about 40 I think
or 50 to create an index hnsw index it
is a bit slower than IVF but with the
latest release uh of PJ Vector it should
be speed up to like three four uh not
sorry like maybe 20 times even
um so we can uh use this query to see
that Vector is being created and after
this amount of seconds
4800 uh index will be created uh with
parameters m equal to 32 and EF
constructions to a EF construction only
affects uh um how like fast will be
index buil and M32 affects
uh uh
Precision greatly uh so let's jump to
Vector search part of an experiment uh
here I use uh a couple of parameters the
first one is parallel one which means
that the first search experiment will be
done in one thread uh and later I use
two Excel uh Ines just POS uh 8 core
machine with uh 32 gigs of
RAM uh so I used parallel 8 and parall
16 also 20 40 and 100 to see how
parallelization of clients that quering
the database will affect the search uh
for the one threaded experiment we see
uh QPS queries per second on the level
of about 70 to
80 uh and it will speed up up to like 16
and 20 it will be around 700 uh 800 quar
per second and then it will go down with
40 and 100 will be about like 400
queries uh per second you see the
difference uh this is because of course
bosg uses M
threats uh to run queries not
subsequently uh so the speed bump is
pretty
noticeable
uh as a result uh it outputs just Json
files uh just Json files uh with some
timings uh Medan P95 P99 uh this is all
done uh by the framework
itself um yeah let's wait just a second
when it will be
over and jump to the results uh so the
first result that I can show you here is
e search and how e search parameter that
can be used during the search phase
actually affects the uh accuracy of
results uh so this is approximate
nearest neighbor search and uh this
means that it uh sometimes returns not
the exact nearest and this signalize how
close are these results to exact nearest
neighbor search uh and if we bump e
search to 100 we get almost 9 St
accuracy
here uh then about how pration affects
the performance and as I mentioned uh we
get about 76 uh QPS for one threat uh
load then we go to 5 to8 for eight
threats for 16 and 20 it's pretty
similar on about like
710 uh QPS and uh when we go higher it
goes to it goes down with
64 40 parallel queries and uh about
430 for 100 uh some more charts here
this is how database feels when we do
all this stuff uh you can see that uh it
wasn't enough
RAM uh for the database to build an
index
efficiently uh that's why it took for
about an hour as I
mentioned uh and probably the good thing
here is use uh database use instance for
the database with more R uh then it will
be able to build index two three times
faster probably maybe even more and the
actual usage of ram when we do queries
is about 16 gigs of uh sorry 20 gigs of
RAM uh this is what pogress use to do
searches
efficiently
uh you can later to this results and
turn them into any charts that you want
this is for example a comparison of hnsw
and IVF flat in
pogress uh on this uh 1 million
embeddings data set by open Ai and as
you can see hnsw performs pretty much
better than IVF flat it is still on the
latest version
0.5.1 uh buil-in index is slower than I
fled by I expect when the latest release
uh will be published uh and this pair
will be merch they will be on par in
terms of index building time as well uh
thank you very much and if you have any
questions I'll be happy to
[Applause]
answer don't be shy yes sure
um thanks for uh thank you for speech
you are using postre SQL for uh
clusterized
data uh because if you have uh if you
have only vectors you can uh put it one
in one place but you uh use
uh relational database why uh well
actually
there are multiple problems uh there was
a conference AI conference recently and
one of the problems that all these
newborn AI startups from last year there
were really a lot of them uh have right
now is that you kind of have problems uh
with access to the data that you store
in vectors as well so if you have
different users you for example create a
service for rug never mind uh or
anything else uh and you provide it to
like multiple companies you may struggle
From perspective of who can see what
data even like in one company some
people like One Department can see some
data the other cannot and when you have
a separate database like quadrant for
example or pine con to store these
vectors uh it is pretty hard to manage
this thing this pogress for example you
have roow level security uh concept I
don't know if you're familiar with this
but in general you can create uh
policies in SQL who can see what if you
have users there and it is pretty
transparent how to manage this and also
with our experiments pogress performs
pretty well in terms of search and index
build
so is also easier to manage because you
have only one database to deploy
and
so thanks for the presentation thank you
very much so uh there were many reasons
for using the postc with the extension
but uh what about reasons not to when
would you not what are the problems it
wouldn't solve as well yeah uh So
currently it is pretty complicated uh to
build with really a lot of vectors like
billions for example billions of open AI
vectors it will be complicated because
you can see here that even this 1
million vectors it uses about 20 gigs of
RAM uh so you can use for example like
in instance with 260 gigs of RAM fit
like maybe 15 million vectors there but
if you want to fit 100 uh you probably
need to Shard this Vector use a lot of
databases and do all this kind of stuff
there is also a pogers based
project uh called green plum it is an
analytics database in general uh it uses
posg I think 12 or 13 I'm not sure what
version exactly but uh they uh you can
deploy it as cluster you can I don't
know like pull 20 30 notes there and it
can do pretty fast K&N searches over the
whole cluster so you just use it as a
database as a normal database and you
can easily put 1 billion vectors there
if you have a lot of compute uh a lot of
instances and it will work but it will
be a bit separate now I wouldn't use for
like billion scale probably just throw
po maybe green plan
yes yeah uh thanks for your speech uh my
question is related to Pine con
similarity search uh if you have ever fa
based yeah just I it as well mhm great
uh so uh our issue is related to like
actually right now we are using pine con
and U with Leng chain uh over open area
right it's like all of them together and
um right now we are we want to solve the
similarity search issue which without
open AI uh like involvement yeah uh no
let's say we have
like a big database on a pine con
collected from uh different documents
right and um uh we want to run our own
uh like a logic uh which will not use uh
open Ai and just use pine con to get the
data uh can you suggest some solutions
about it
uh yes probably uh if you don't want to
use embedding CPI
from open a right uh what languages do
you use
for in what languages at the moment it's
JavaScript but uh we want to the the the
data itself uh that you create
embeddings from uh what is the
data you store embeddings in P what is
the data yeah yeah the text like Uhl
English English yeah probably I would
use just GT small model GT small GTE
yeah like GTE GTE GTE small model it's
uh there is a paper from Chinese I don't
remember what research laboratory made
it uh it is a very good very performant
model uh it has 384 Dimensions the only
drawback for
it is that it can only support English
so if docents are in English you can
easily use this I think there is also GT
large for some other languages but GT
small is like perfect we in general
recommend using this model because
vectors are smaller you can store more
vectors you can do searches faster
everything is better MH thank you yeah
and in terms of testing uh Pine con and
P Vector in general P Vector is a little
bit cheaper uh maybe like three four
times cheaper than Pine Con on
relatively large LS for for example like
this data set uh so um at the end like
we can avoid from open air right um if
you only use it for embedding generation
yes you can use GTS easily if you use it
for example for llm as well yeah uh then
you probably want to deploy something
like
Mixr uh model or llama model uh which
one sorry Mixr 7B model there is a
pretty good model right now Mixr 88
x7b uh which performs pretty well in llm
benchmarks uh it uses a a concept that
uh maybe Char GT4 also use uh uh when
you have a several experts they generate
something and then there are other
experts that choose the best results out
of it and then you receive the final
answer from the model uh so we can uh
give a question with the same like logic
but different ways and it will give us a
yeah it it works like chpt or it's it's
also a large language model but it's
open source okay
okay and and it's free for commercial
use as well oh that's that's great thank
you and uh I want to use opportunity
second question uh is it possible to
give a question about super base yes
sure yeah I know that you work there and
we we use sa base as well and yeah we
found it very
useful yeah it's really good good job
and but for sure it's uh new and there
are lot of things like we we are trying
to figure out right and um one is uh it
has some cash uh when we manually create
a new table in database it doesn't get
automatically update it seems like there
is a cash or we understand that should
be done through migrations maybe in the
dashboard or uh in dashboard yeah when
we create it manually not through
migrations uh oh uh I I will pass it to
the frontend team probably there is some
issue with just updating the state uh so
the front end is react app database
should really work pretty fast on this
so when you create oh I think I know
it's it's because like how the dashboard
works work actually there is a project
called PG meta uh that is used for
executing like queries for creating a
table or uh adding a column and stuff
like this and when you create a table
through the dashboard it actually has
separate calls uh from the dashboard to
the database to the P meta and then to
the database to create a table and then
to add each column separately but when
you do it from migrations from pcq any
other POG client it's instantaneous so
it will work much like yes it is made
like so uh just because we don't want
security problems when you do this
through the dashboard ah I see I see
thank you very
much hello thanks for it's disabled
thanks for presentation I uh uh wonder
do you have uh knowledge or experience
about chroma versus pine cone the pro
and Cones like performance and other
other stuff unfortunately not I don't
know a lot about
chroma uh I can speak about Pine con uh
a little bit but yeah if you want okay
what is the advantage of pine con like
for other versus other
databases in terms of advantages when I
used Pine con I noticed that it's super
straightforward if you especially if
you're like non-technical or something
like this to create a collection to
populate it with data it is very
straightforward both on their dashboard
and their apis and clients they're super
easy to use
uh that's the big plus and also it
scales very
linearly and uh you can easily draw like
how many you will spend on Pine con if
you grow in terms of how many queries
per second you want to execute or how
many uh vectors you want to store it's
very easy and very transparent as I see
it in terms of Dr bags it's pretty
expensive and you have to always like
it's pretty hard to put your data from
Pine con if you want to move out uh
that's all I guess okay thank you
thank you very much I have a question
regarding um basically the embedding
size so let's say you create a 100 I
don't know word embedding Vector of text
uh and I I wanted to understand whether
the embedding should be similar for
better results and also should the
embedding size be uh kind of similar to
the equation size so what would be a
practical kind of advice
there so if I understand the question
correctly the size of is always the same
because it's the vector you can think of
it as an array of numbers FL I mean like
the representation of the text like so
the text size which you convert to
vectors yeah it doesn't matter so Vector
is always a vector it
has I mean regarding the search results
let's say you convert 1,000 W uh kind of
paragraph into vectors and one three
word paragraph regarding the search
results would it perform the same or
would it perform better with similar
sizes uh size in what term because
Vector has like chunk size like the uh
chunk size yeah basically that you
convert the chunks of text into vectors
and depending on the size of the chunk
uh uh can uh the performance of the
database improve which search uh the
vector uh when you create an embeding a
vector it doesn't matter how big was the
chunk of TCH text or an image or music
that you turned into Vector it will
always be the same size for the database
for the embedding Bing will be for
example like
1536 Dimension Bing it will be always be
the same size and the same will be for
search essentially because like all the
vectors are the same after they turned
into
vectors um maybe I yeah thank you very
much
oh uh you mean sorry excuse me uh if you
mean uh the dimensionality of the
vector okay can
iate yes sure
question so given we have like a big
text and we want to split it into chunks
right before giving it likeing the
embeddings so does the chunk size should
be similar to the question size with
which we are going to do the similarity
search is there any correlation between
like similarity of the two sizes or it
still will perform uh as good as in case
of similar size if for example the chunk
embedded chunk is like 100 times bigger
than the question chunk thank you uh so
I don't have a qu answer for this but uh
it will depend on the model that you use
uh for embeddings because apart from the
database database just compares to
vectors that's just mathematical
operation basically cosign similarity do
product anything uh and can I add one
thing I'm sorry sorry can I add one
thing um uh there was a paper published
it was called Lost in the middle and uh
in the paper it is stated when uh the
the text Chunk is uh bigger uh the
information in the middle is uh most
probably lost so llm mods pays more
attention to the beginning and the end
and I think the chunk of the text
matters when you do
embeddings uh yes sure and that was the
second part of my answer so there are no
I think like a single point of view on
how you should split your text or any
other information to chunks for example
open Ai and most of their examples just
chunk it by uh couple new lines or some
fixed amount like 4,000 tokens or
something like this and uh when a lot of
researchers or practical users they look
at this uh they think that this is a bad
idea but still use it because I think
you're right about the paper uh that
smaller chunks better but I'm not sure
that it should be the same size as the
question yeah thanks for presentation uh
from the perspective of super base like
you acting as like selfhosted service is
there plans to include with the PG vtor
as well some mding models selfhosted or
llm selfhosted for your
users uh yes uh so we have both
self-hosted and Cloud versions and uh we
do have plans to do this either in Edge
functions uh runtime or as a part of the
storage engine we do not yet have a
fully working PC on this but this is
definitely pled
thank
you thank
[Applause]
you